yeah white dudes like that have a high
libido huh who Larry King yeah like him
and like what was the Playboy guy um he
h Hefner like you know when they were 80
and stuff they were they were staring at
their like ET dicks right I don't know
what they do though like I feel like I
remember hearing from one of the
Playmates who told her story that like
they would just kind of all sit in the
bed and like kiss each other I don't
think sex happened but I don't know oh
that's weird like a slumber party yeah
but didn't he actually produce spawn
when in his 70s me which one Larry King
oh probably I don't know yeah imagine if
there was no [__] Viagra yeah and he
still had to have sex he would have to
take Jam his oh
stop smooshies yeah he would smoosh it
against the wall of the vagina the word
Jam yeah he would not Jam um I would do
it a little differently if I was him and
I I was 70 and I knew that I could still
ejaculate yeah I would put it on a Petra
dish and then get a turkey baster and
then turkey Bas no I would I would take
my four fingers like this oh no and I
would rub it like a
clip right like and honey you know and
and she would be spread right I would
right that's what he does you ready you
ready right right and I would then take
this thing and spread the vaginal open
and just try to eject you just shoot it
into it is that do I am I perverted
about even saying
now I know that's exactly my style now
and I just feel like am I Larry King I
don't know but this is who I was before
Yoga
Yoga that's just a bunch of
stretching that's not a real exercise
you know like anyone that would do yoga
i' be like oh yeah yeah I also
walk you know what I mean like that's
how the level of I thought that it was
just like walking or lifting your arm
mhm right ooh yoga hard right just
lifting your arms like that right this
right I don't know why I'm doing this
you've been doing that a lot like air
traffic haven't blown in so long I don't
know I'm doing I don't know why when
you're happy with your weight clap your
hands fat fat wait so but what would you
say about yoga now before you said oh no
so I'm going to get into it oh it is
um it is the most difficult thing I've
ever done in my life I've been in into a
lot of TR tragic situations in my life a
lot of physical exertion you have I've
been beat up yeah I've been uh you know
I used to have this trainer you know cuz
Abby thought one time that I was going
to be like an action star a manager so
she's like I know this guy you know he's
the best trainer in the world this a
tall a muscular black guy and he used to
come to my house and he used to
[__] you're not done and I'm and I'm
on the treadmill you're not done he
would yell you're not done and I go I'm
dying and then like if I would stop he
would grab me and put me back on the TR
you're not doing you know and I was so
hard this is way worse you know there's
no way that's possible oh yeah dude
there okay what what I love about yoga
is this she's like you'll be in a
position right what is that position
you'll be on a okay you'll be on your
leg like this one leg and you're lifting
it like this I'm just getting making it
up right and she's I'm I'm like it burns
right and then well because you haven't
you know used certain muscles there
before right like you know some of us
have built up that muscle right but
because it burn because you haven't used
and in my mind I'm like when would I
ever be in this
position how could I work on this I
would have to be able am I kicking a if
I was a soccer player like this maybe
this right wow that's really good babe
so fible right
but when would you ever that's why this
is petrified cuz I'm never in this
position so it's very difficult you know
um you have you done yoga I have there's
a a Youtube yoga that I do yoga with
Cassandra but hers
is you talking hers is mostly stretching
so I like stretching yoga I don't like
working yoga can you please do yoga you
and Dave too yeah that he would do it
yeah it be I would just want to see him
do it well he doesn't want that he's so
he doesn't want to be seen he can just
be off screen I feel like I'm at a
position or a Point with David that he
should be able to allow me to see him
tell him that I think we're at at that
point I yeah I'm definitely open to
starting that conversation he's really
he that's like his worst fear though is
people watching him try to exercise like
he the thought of like a work workout
class is just like the that's his worst
fear I would I and he could be doing it
perfectly I don't know why but because
whenever I see David it makes me want to
laugh yeah he's funny he's just a funny
joyful you know bundle of joy and um I
just know that if I saw him do yoga that
I would probably burst into
laughter I wouldn't be able to stop
myself so maybe not do it okay yeah yeah
yeah I don't but you always last night I
need three things this is what she said
in the a scavenger hunt I need yeah
three things is a scavenger hun no
longer a favor very very keep in mind
that I'm already tucked in it doesn't I
don't keep that in mind done because
it's not like a metallic sheet that
you're [__] you know me you could hang
on I had also had I stopped moving all
day yesterday it doesn't just let me
finish the story I I clean everything
can I finish my story it doesn't matter
I need three things right so at that
point you have to bring out a notebook
it's a quest and a [__] pencil what
is it like you're now a secretary right
you're like Gus needs to be unfilled
okay Gus Gus is our um Roomba
oh cuz first of all I had to I had to
empty out Gus three times so this is the
third time I had to empty out Gus yeah
right so Gus needs to be empty again I
just [__] did it 10 minutes ago
[__] G he eats too much right number
two I want some water and she goes she
not just water it needs to be filled
okay that's another thing when he gives
me cups of water it's always half filled
I don't understand why he can't just sit
there for two more seconds seconds she
wants specific amount 8 ounces a glass 8
o no [__] all right so I have to get an
hour measuring
cup pull out the measuring cup measuring
cup yeah I have to get the measuring cup
or just fill it to the to no I get the
measuring cup you know what I do is when
I need I asked for water now Dave knows
to ask which which cup because I have
asked if you a specific cup yeah keep
going I'm loving this the third thing or
he puts it in like a coffee mug and
that's not 8 oz and if it's the glass
that you need by your bedside that's
just not enough water if that's not good
enough for you get your own [__]
water she and the third thing is I need
a Halls which is okay but now I have to
now now this is what this is the voyage
yeah I got to empty up guys go to the
trash
can right then go to the thing get the
[__] Halls right then get the
measuring cups measuring cup measuring
cup measuring cup Ladle yeah that's four
cups okay you bring it to her right and
that's 20
minutes interesting and this is always
his face when he he brings you what he
needs oh it's the best face you know I
think about the face he wants to punish
you with his I think about the face when
I'm bringing the [__] to her what face
am I going to do what
yeah yeah I love the face but it's like
and I've never asked for anything so
Dave has Dave ever asked you for
anything hey sweetie can you go get me
you know it's very rare a fruit roll up
you never ask for anything I just don't
believe that oh my God Esther I am a
glorified [__] boy I can go ahead
whatever I asked for everything can you
get the first thing you cried every day
when I didn't want to buy an extra
freezer for all your [__] pizzas and
C every day she was like where's my
[__] freezer and then you know what
you did yesterday what did you say
yesterday what what she was like you
said this how many times do I have to
ask you to buy me my my what do you call
your habaniro
sauce I did say that yesterday how many
times do I have to ask you to buy Meo
song you know what I did while I was
asking she she was wearing bare feet she
had bare feet and I had I was cleaning I
was doing
laundry and I had my Barefoot I stamped
on her I stomped on her foot and I I I
she was in the closet and I stomped on
her foot I put my hand here so she
couldn't escape I go how many times do I
have to ask you to get me my [__]
Happ Nero sauce jumar
isman yeah so he doesn't ask he demands
but here's the de Deens it's it sounds
so superficial right it sounds so it but
no listen okay I've been asking for that
hobos SAU for a [__] month
and every time I said what's the name no
I be honest you knew the name the first
time I did know the I look it up and I
did tell you but I said do not throw the
jar right and of all the things that you
don't throw around the house for
miraculously you throw hingo company or
something like that but I'm just curious
like look I'm just curious go ahead is
there ever a world where you could
yourself order the freezer or the sauce
you know that's an interesting question
let's break down and I'm going to break
that question
down yes is there a before he breaks it
down Esther I will say it's not that he
doesn't try it's just that it always
ends up in the wrong address because he
doesn't know his own
address yeah yeah um my bottom that I
should have quit drinking at was in
Santa Fe I was I was drinking really
heavily and I left it was my friend's
30th birthday party yeah and I went I
was 21 or 25 and I uh I went like I was
like oh my God it's your birthday buy me
Shots like that's oh my God it's your
birthday like buy me drinks this is
great and he kept buying me shots I was
wasted and I was like so drunk I was
like I'm gonna suck your dick for your
birthday I'm gonna blow you and I was
working at it I was working at this
Cowboy Bar that's where we were drinking
where you had to wear I'm like in a
cowboy hat like I'm G suck your dick sir
and um and I had a motor scooter that
used to drive around like I go beep beep
hottie and i' pull my tits out Sant is
such a small town it's like I was just
totally known I was Infamous yeah yeah
and um and then we so I was like going
to drive and he was like no you can't
ride your scooter and I was like [__]
you everyone's like out on the patio
looking at me I'm like tit out like yeah
right beep beep later [__] I like
peel off and make a turn I'm done I wake
up the next day with my face split open
my just like I had to get nine stitches
it looked like my my the dress I was
wearing it looked like someone had slit
my throat there was just blood it I
looked like Carrie I had Road Rash I
almost lost nipple it was so bad all my
tits for the next month after that my my
pickup line at the bars was like hey you
want to rub some neopor on my titties I
had to carry who wants to do like open
gushy wound wow and then my friend took
me to the hospital everything but I kept
thinking like at least I got those
wounds instead of getting like the the
wounds that come back on my
genitals [__] two months if I gone
and [__] my friend Albert youve never
had so disgusting I had crabs in college
which is why I think I do comedy yeah
when when they when they diagnosed the
crabs I thought it was so funny like
there was no my only I was like couldn't
wait to tell everyone well crabs was a
hot commodity in the late 90s and early
2000s I remember I remember when Snoop
Dogg came on Power 106 and he was like I
you know I got the little soldiers and
everyone's like yeah so I thought crabs
was the least at the bottom the best
they were so funny I was like of all the
STDs to get hilarious I I'm not a
science guy but um I don't when they say
crabs are they literal crabs oh my my
God they're Li yes they're pubic lies so
if you have a microscope don't don't
laugh at me you don't need a mic keep
dude I just learned I thought they were
tiny little crabes yeah yeah that's why
yeah yeah don't be don't be an [__]
it makes dick look really big though
when you use
the really good because I just found
about Kanan what it Kanan it's Q andon
qon today I mean I just found out about
that Kanan you know what I mean but um
so I like how you're pretending like you
don't know what it's
called he's been on Mad to yeah yeah so
when you see um um when you have crabs
and you look in the microscope do they
look like crabs yeah they look crazy
yeah they're little lice yeah yeah well
I saw them first I was itching my mom
was in town I was like Mom there's
something wrong with my vagina my mom's
like does not ever want to hear any of
that she's like ew I'm like that's not I
need you and then um I went to the my I
left my mom at home and I went to the
doctor or to the school nurse I was in
college and she was like you don't have
crabs and I was like like I do have cra
oh you have crabs I could see them the
girl that I saw before you I want to say
her name but we had sex we call her dumb
[__] dumb [__] yeah yeah she after she
we had hooked up the first time yeah she
just looks at me she goes I just want
you know I should have told you before
but I have um STDs I should have told
you how many what do you mean how many
and which ones very I don't know which
one it was it was a specific but I go
why I anticipated this so on the first
the first month that we dated I got
tested serially like I got a series of
tests what did it come back it come back
good she had Corona yeah no
no started there it started there no no
serious ones okay yeah yeah thankfully
but yeah I think that's something you
should say you know before up yeah but
it's like I mean like really I done
anyway I would done it anyway and I love
I love your interactions interactions
interactions with Esther there's like a
screaming thing that goes on what when
we come in and we're like sir sir do you
mind leaving is she is he bothering you
yeah yeah we both put our cameras on and
like attack each other when we see each
other uh I'm also her lawyer I'm always
suing people for her I'm like I'm also
her lawyer ma'am I'm gonna have to but
it's like Esther's doing stand up like
it's an open mic right and then Annie
would be like commit to it finish finish
the thought heckling finish the thought
right and then and then's like I'm
trying I don't know I I don't know what
the premise is well Esther keeps
pretending she doesn't know to do
[__] comedy she's been doing it for
13 I I know she is one of those Esther's
so funny she's like I don't know how to
write a joke and then she's just saying
jokes all day I'm like Esther it's like
just you have to do tap tap tap yeah for
one second she's so
lazy there was a little bit of lazy well
this is I what I have as a premise right
and then she wants ask to R yeah she's
like um so I woke up yeah this morning a
little late she's like you know people
are just throwing her punch lines I
check her my Instagram yeah is that
relatable yeah yeah but she really is um
I have to say about Esther she's an
anomaly she's so funny they're just so
unique as a human you know she's very
talented and um you know um I just I I
just loved being there because in this
pandemic I just I don't really seen
anybody and to see you girls you know um
such a fun H it's such a good time over
there yeah and am I mean to you I mean
we're pretty I like us now what do you
mean I feel like our relationship feels
good yeah you didn't like him at first
no I loved I looked up to him but he
hated me when I first joined this I
looked he was my like the only Asian on
network TV she was like my boyfriend's
Bobby I'm like oh my God I'd love to
help the first thing he does he's like
you suck you're gay no I said called you
a FL you gay no I'm
not hey for two years you got everyone
on this podcast I think I was in a gay
relationship he's so good it but I used
to call you like flat face flat face
fairy boy you flat face why cuz he's a
flat face
no you got a
flat the [__] you talking about he look
like he was born over here you look like
you was brought over
here [__] is you talking about
yeah recing right he look like he's from
Hawaii yeah yeah yeah I look like I'm
from like old school Asia well I can't
talk about y'all right now you trying to
[__] good we're good no we're not
good once you release this
[__] you trying to set a [__] up
I ain't got time for that [__] I ain't
saying [__] bad about you I appreciate
my
hair did you did you grow up with
Asians uh no no not until you guys came
to our community oh we came to your
community interest yeah the beauty
supply
store
store you ever grocery store we ever
friends with Asians growing up they
didn't go to my school no oh when's the
first time you became a friend with an
Asian
you
you 49 years
later I'm trying to think I don't know
no
Asian I'm not Lord I'm not being racist
but I really don't know no Asian okay so
let me just be honest then can I may I
be honest yeah I grew up with in the
suburbs of San Diego there was no black
people how many do you have in your
school one and a half I don't even know
wow mean I had a white was really tan I
don't know maybe you know he was black
but there are some suburbs in San Diego
that are super white like so white so
it's like the only real like black
friends I got was from Comedy yeah and
then you just show up at a club and then
like you know you see I the first guy I
met was this kid named Kareem right and
he was this tall he had a big fro and he
just came up to me and he goes what's up
man and then he gave me he gave me a hug
and I'm like I couldn't believe it I was
like it's just like in the
movies spit on me and right on my no no
you know mean and I try to do the like I
try to be like you know he gave me a hug
and when we departed I was just like
like you know I did a thing with my body
wow and I couldn't believe it was like
I'm I'm in training day or something you
know God damn Bobby we we had one we had
one episode about race yeah things you
shouldn't say and you and and the word
in in the show that I brought up was [__]
slap you you ever heard of that word I
like it what it is that's what that's
what my dad did to my
mom
[__] jump oh you so stupid but so I
grew up as a little girl and I'm just
innocent I'm telling the story and um I
grew up as a little girl and we watched
a lot of K fu movie Bruce Lee everybody
love Bruce Lee and um my mom used to
walk around I say I'mma jab slap the
[__] out of you
but holy [__] I love it that's a
derogatory terms against Asian people I
didn't know that to my husband say that
is racist as [__] and I say why he said
cuz when U when Asians uh uh was uh was
in a concentration camp or something
that's what they did [__] slapped them
hit them from the back you know with the
back of their hand and I'm like well I
didn't know that [__] so when I did the
derogatory uh episode which is about
[__] hky cracker uh we said all of
these words um [__] slaps and at the time
Asians had just started getting beat on
and the network lost their [__] mind
like we got to remove ja slap so we
tried to come up with so many other
words and they picks and I'm like chinks
is the worst that's worse than that's
that's the N word for Asians but I was
like thank you everybody know they said
cheek on
TV wow yeah but it's it's all about it's
a teaching moment you got my you know
like when you when you're a parent and
you're used to it's almost like what uh
Matt dami just said when he was saying
the f word it's so that's the episode
that I just shot where the kids come in
and say hey you can't say that anymore
well [__] why y'all keep
changing this [__] yeah yeah you know
it's almost like when you see a older
white man who say colors yeah well if
that [__] been living in the
country he used to say in colors and
that's what he just used to and if don't
nobody correct him then to me that
person is not racist that person is
ignorant you have to put people in
context with either the time or the area
right and their life experiences they
exposed to but but that's why I was
never offended by Archie Bunker because
I knew when I watched that character I
believed that character really existed
it was what the [__] you mean and he was
authentic he was very authentic
authentic that's why white men loved him
because he was the voice of that era and
what he was saying out loud was
beginning to fade away for them ah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because time times
was changing and you wasn't allowed to
you those at the time they could still
say it but they knew that they was
losing that opportunity to talk like
that oing in public without you know but
what I like about Archie is that he
would also learn though on the show and
grow and you knew that deep down inside
he's not a bad guy he's not a bad guy
right right he's just a guy that grew up
in a time period he's ignorant ignorant
that's right he's ignorant and when when
an ethnic people person sees something
like that in art or television stuff we
get it well you're going to love this
[__] [__] I can't wait cuz that's
what this episode is about about the
ignor of of me you know I even did an
episode on um uh I don't even know what
they call them but them day and them
them day and there oh the pronouns
pronouns yeah my daughter brought a
pronoun on house what's them pronouns PR
them there instead of she she he she her
he him yeah they don't want to be called
boy and girl so they say they them there
and there so my daughter bring over this
boy one day yeah and the boy to me and
uh and he was like I'm I got pronouns
I'm like you got a
dick you know what facts though but you
know it was a teaching moment for me and
I decided to bring that life real life
experience what it was to deal with a
real child who had a pronoun who parents
didn't want to accept that the changes
this child was going through and I
brought it into an episode which was
true to my family and it was [__]
hilarious wow yes it's episode 4 and my
daughter wrote the episode she did yeah
my daughter wrote on the show oh wow wow
that's awesome are you knee deep in dick
right now or no no because you but I
would like to
be I would love to be slashing through
the swamp dicks figuring out which dick
would be the best dick for my vagina was
it easier to get dick before yeah way
easier to get dick before cuz they
thought you needed them yeah you know
you know men love a girl that needs to
be rescued a damel in distress wow you
know once you get a certain they think
you're rich they think you like well she
doesn't need me like and they'll
approach you and it's like a lot of guys
that approach me are gold diggers you
got your gold diggers you got your you
got your uh ego Maniacs that are like
yeah I just want to be able to say I
[__] Tiffany hadish you know and then
you got you know the actual good guys
but they might be not my type or boring
and then then you find maybe you might
find something right in the middle did
you point
at he's a good guy but he's no one's
type
you what mean look good to me
yeah I like how his heartbeating
fast look look his face look at his face
his heart is beating baby that's the
same color of as dick look at
that you like a really pink dick like
that I don't think you like that I mean
in the dark it's cool but yeah the
lights come on you're like oh my God are
you
bleeding no no no it's like just hard
yeah
wow so um that that is interesting I
don't hate those dicks though I love all
dicks have you ever had Asian dick yes
you have Mr Kim yes
Mr what is he Delivery Man for chines no
Mr Kim was a he owned race horses and
cattle and he like imported exported to
Korea like uh cattle and stuff and uh
the horses he would like train all that
stuff he's rich as [__] was he Korean
yeah that's Korean yeah yeah Korean and
was he older yeah way he was like 20
years older than me wow and he was the
first man to make me have an orgasm
without actually touching my vagina wow
I saw I saw what the [__] how you do
that how you do that fun to [__] some
kind
of what is happening like Asians have
magic yeah yeah that's why they got
massage parlors everywhere wow Mr Kim
was great what did he live in a ranch
somewhere in LA or somewhere he he had a
ranch in Portland he had something else
in like Utah or whatever and he had like
houses two three houses here in La did
you always call him Mr Kim I always
called him Mr Kim he introduced himself
to me as Mr
Kim I mean I believe his first name was
Roger or whatever Roger Kim he told me
to call him Mr Kim and that's wowow and
then um how did you but how would you
meet a Mr Kim um I met him when I was
working at the airlines I was working at
the Airlines and my station manager
introduced me to him he's like this is a
really good cuz uh it was funny cuz
everybody's like Tiffany needs a man you
need a good man like to like Wrangle you
in and a older man so you can learn from
him and so my station manager introduced
me to Mr Kim and and like yeah we dated
for probably like a year he got me like
expensive backpacks and necklaces wow
and like took me on trips and stuff took
horse races I loved Mr Kim too and then
he just disappeared oh he did yeah
probably went home to his wife or
something I don't know if he had one but
I assume that had to be it or he died
oh no Mr Kim got rip [__] yeah he's
probably alive I don't know he probably
so proud of you though if he remembers
me oh Mr Kim do you think Mr Kim
remembers looks up and he's like oh my
God I feel like if he's still alive and
he looks up and he goes something about
that girl he had an accent he had an
accent accent oh [__] that's a game
changer that's a game changer well that
shows wow a lot it reveals a lot to you
about you Bobby oneon-one is one
of the coolest human being beautiful
person you are beauti and generous and
attentive and then he he UPS the yeah
and then he gets around these dicks and
he tries to be a dick and it's like it's
not who you are bro it doesn't [__]
work he's not a dick no he's at all no
but he's a dick around other people yeah
and it's doesn't make any [__] sense
it's confusing who are you right
now because the thing is is that um when
you're around some of these guys there's
a there's a feeling you know with with
like last night I was with Spade Kalen
Jeff Ross all these guys and when you
get around it you I I can feel myself I
can feel myself not being me because
mainly it's because I'm trying to
protect myself around them yeah cuz
you're afraid you're going to be under
attack right but they can't attack
what's real and they can try to attack
it but they'll never win the battle
right cuz it's real
yeah wow I do I do you know it's so
funny you're the first comic to ever say
that out loud that I do do that yeah I
observe it within
myself when I'm there and amongst them I
observe it and then I I observe myself
who I'm authentically me when I'm
one-on-one with even a younger comic and
I can just like you know Sunday night my
MC Joe who's the parking lot guy at the
Joe Murray the parking guy at the store
you know him and he no one ever asked
him to go on the road with him he's only
open for one dude one time maybe three
or four years ago and so um him and I
after the meal I go you hungry he goes
yeah let's go to Cheesecake Factory we
just sat there yeah I pay for everything
you know and we get to talk play games
and and make each other laugh and talk
you know I mean and I'm but if Joe
Maurice saw me with deah and all these
other guys I would not shun him but I
would block him out right so many Comics
did that to me over the years I know and
then they come now they're like hey Tiff
what's up and I'm like
hey wow I treat them the way they
treated me like I treat people the way I
want to be treated and however they
treated me well I'm I'm just a
reflection of that yeah so I'm like hey
what up like you know if you would have
if you would have never came
around I probably would be like what the
[__] do you want me to do he not doing
the podcast tiger
what give you my number
why yeah yeah you know but you know what
I'll be honest with you if I didn't come
around and you had blown up I would not
ever ask you and and let me say this and
this is the truth I would probably live
the rest of my life going why did I do
that yeah cuz he does have a lot of
those relationships where that he's
completely blown where he'll tuck his
tail between his legs and say you know
what I'm not even going to try because I
[__] up yeah but you should be the
bigger man and be like yo I want I
apologize for that man that is true and
walk away from it and see if they come
back yeah but to me it it's it's if
they've blown the like okay if I was
really mean to somebody which is I can
only think of maybe one at the top of my
head me no not you not you cuz you're
here you're [__] here but I can think
of one that I can't name the name but
like U that blew the [__] up that I
wasn't really that nice to not I wasn't
a dick but I just remember just you know
they would say hi and I go know not you
know not really open and now this person
is huge and um I don't want to go hey
sorry because the thing is is that it's
going to make it seem apology as an
incentive that I'm apologizing to get
something out of it or well if you ask
for something right after you apologize
then yeah that's what it's going to seem
like but if you apologize and then move
on with your existence and you guys
happen to meet up again which will
happen if you are running in the same
clubs okay it'll be a different
situation yeah so this is what I'm going
to say well what's up dude you know
honestly like I'm I don't want anything
out of you you know I'm just here
because I just when you were a younger
guy you know I just was kind of like I
ignored you and I was kind of a dick at
a lot of times and I just want
congratulations I'm really proud of you
and uh I just wanted to apologize for
that behavior and um Good Luck for is
that good yeah and then keep it pushing
and then you keep it pushing keep it
pushing I'm going to [__] do it
you'll feel better afterwards too you
won't feel the guilt you feel or
whatever you're feeling
you won't feel that anymore cuz you did
your part now if that person continues
to treat you like [__] or whatever if
they even treating you like anything you
know but nine times out of 10 they will
appreciate it